one of the things about structure that I
found that sort of changed more than
anything for me because I didn't realize
this for the first 10 or 15 years that I
was a consultant and lecturer and that
is I always thought a plot structure I
mean it was the sequence of events and
the things that happened and that's sort
of externally so this need and it is it
is a plot structure and there are
certain key things that need to happen
at 25 percent 50 percent 75 but the
revelation to me was when I realized
that the inner journey the character
takes also has a structure and it's
exactly the same structure the same six
stages apply to that and when you really
get that in fact I've not knowing
anything about directing actors but
you've heard my lecture about that I've
often thought from an actor's point of
view if an actor understood formulaic ly
where characters would be in this arc
depending on where in the script it
would be it could really inform the
performance because they would they
would realize if I've just if I'm at the
midpoint of this story I'm going to have
to make a bigger commitment than I've
ever made and that's going to be
terrifying
but once I do now I'm going to be moving
more steadily into my essence so
whatever it might be and that
intertwining of that outer journey and
inner journey as I said before that to
me is where it gets both fascinating and
really helpful to writers because they
can really integrate those two things in
fact that would be a good wood seminar a
one weekend seminar there's no the inner
journey from the writers side and from
the actors side do you know I mean doing
a just sort of putting those two
exploring those two together somehow
we're going to be doing it in the in the
weekend we're already doing I'm sure
that's going to come up because I'm
going to be talking about that and I'll
just bring it up because I've always
been curious about that and we'll see if
if that is helpful to actors because I
don't know and it might not be but we'll
see does it mesh with the process you
use
actors in directing them and is it
helpful for you as a director or for the
actors to know well this occurs at this
point in the script at this point in the
inner journey so being aware of that
helps or does that lead them more to
trying to get the result you were
talking about I think it could help a
lot with the actors just to know that
getting back to my way of working with
actors I don't want them to be holding
so tenaciously to that you know so that
the actor brain is just overworking
itself but to know that oh yeah okay I
know I'm at the midpoint I'm knowing
this is a crucial thing I know that much
more important and it's great for the
actor for the director to know that so
the director of the directors
interrogating the character the director
is leading the character to that level
of intensity or focus and the actor
knows that we're going that way but it
still has to be the combination between
the director not just the actor on their
own right well because a character in a
movie wouldn't know it no no but a
character but but the director can
increase or decrease an intensity or a
focus of that moment that's right to
match to say because I know where we are
in the story exactly I agree I'm
agreeing completely because the director
could have that in mind and it would be
helpful but if you're trying to reach
the character and the character said
well I just crossed the point of no
return that's the actor taught us the
actor types yes because in real life we
don't know how afraid we are it's all
subconscious unconscious we don't know
when we're up against it as much as we
are we don't know that it's going to
have a happy and we usually think
otherwise even though it's a Hollywood
movie it usually does
you